peu plus
[Musique]
je les trouvais devant ma porte
un soir que je rentrais chez moi partout
elle me fait escaudes et les revenus la
vologne
la religieuse les fourneaux de le meux
suivi pas à pas la garde que le dior
l'emportent
elle est revenue et les leurs avec sa
gueule de carême avec ses larges aux
yeux cernés
elle nous fait le coeur à la traîne elle
nous fait le coeur à pleurer elle nous
fait mal
de longues nuits des sols et la garce
elle nous ferait même l'hiver au plein
coeur de l'été
triste europe deux mois avec ses cheveux
mal peigné timing du désespoir du léman
bel orgue un délai at on par ailleurs
patrice que le taux l'ennui je n'ai pas
le goût du malheur va en voir ailleurs
si jc je veux encore rouler des hanches
je veux me saouler de printemps
je veux m'en payer des nuits blanches
car tvo
l'europe attend à vente et son neveu me
jusqu'à mon souffle dernier je veux
encore dire je t'aime et vouloir mourir
d'aimer elle a dit moi ta peau de goethe
avait suivi pas à pas je sais que tes
amours sont mortes je suis revenue me
follow il tend réussit l om eu des beaux
messieurs étaient fausses enfants tu
t'es fort un beau test d'haleine
eh bien c'est fini maintenant depuis je
me fais des nuits blanches
elle s'est pendue à mon goût elle
s'étend ou les mélanges et ce couvent
mais genou au retour de cet escroc
feront le matin de fond ma porte
elle est revenue et la place aux
la solitude
[Musique]